MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
In this section, we want to
study the decay of a particle,
in this case, the
decay of a pion.
The pion is a particle
which consists
of quarks and antiquarks, which
are bound together by gluons.
They're part of a
family of particles
which are called mesons.
And they can be
charged and neutral.
So we have positively-charged,
negatively-charged, and neutral
pions.
In this example, we
look at a neutral pion
decay and the specific
decay into an electron
and a positron.
Mostly, neutral pions and
decay into a pair of photons.
But we study this effect
here because it's more fun.
The lifetime or the
mean lifetime over pi 0
is 8 times 10 to the
minus 17 seconds.
So when we produce neutral
pions in our detector,
they immediately
decay, as I said,
mostly into a pair of photons.
That we discovered in the 1940s.
So let's get to it.
So the mass of a pion--
of neutral pion is 135 MeV.
So it's much heavier than
an electron, which is 500--
has a mass of 511 KeV.
So we're looking
at this decay here.
We have a pion a rest into
an electron and a positron.
And so the charge for you
now is to find the gamma
factor of the electron
or the positron
or, [? with ?] that, the
velocity of those particles
and the decay of a pion at rest.
So again, as usual,
stop the video,
and try to work this out.
And again, what we want to do is
just write down the four-vector
of the particles involved.
We start with the
pion, which has
an energy of the pion
mass times c square.
And it's at rest in
this example here,
which means that
the momentum is 0.
And so then the
outgoing particles
are the electron and
positron with their energy
and their momentum.
And then just from
this first line
here from the energy
relation, you can--
by knowing that the mass of
the electron and a positron
are the same, by knowing
that the gamma factor is
the same that comes out of
the momentum relation here,
that they have
the same velocity,
you can just simply
find gamma as
equal to the pion mass divided
by 2 times the electron mass.
And that is about 132.
So again, we studied
the decay of a pion.
And as a general
example of the decay
of a particle into
two new particles,
we used the energy
momentum relation.
We make sure use of the
[? effect, ?] in this case,
that we are in the
rest frame of the pion.
And then we are able to get
to the velocity or the gamma
factor of the
outgoing particles.